.
# U sie stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüm meh hei.
Schwere Maschinen ...
# Sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
... ein grosser Traum ...
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
Mein erstes Picknick bei -20 °C.
... und viele Hürden.
Von diesem Tag an
war das halbe Dorf arbeitslos.
Wolltet ihr zurück?- Ja, wir schau-
ten uns Häuser in der Schweiz an.
Man ersäuft schlichtweg
in diesem Schnee.
Eine Reise
ins Land der grossen Freiheit.
* Motorbrummen *
* Hupen *
Oi!
Ich bin zu Besuch
bei Familie Volk in Kanada.
Ein Wiedersehen im tiefsten Winter.
# Sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Anschwellende Musik *
Knapp 8'000 km von der Schweiz
entfernt, ganz im Westen Kanadas.
Ich bin unterwegs
in der Provinz British Columbia,
einem Sehnsuchtsziel
vieler Auswanderer.
Draussen ist es eisig: -11 °C.
Mit dem Wind
fühlt es sich an wie etwa -20 °C.
Aber die Temperaturen waren wohl
noch Familie Volks kleinstes Problem,
als sie vor acht Jahren
hier nach Kanada auswanderte.
Sie mussten
einige Hindernisse überwinden.
Ich bin gespannt, ob sie hier mitt-
lerweile trotzdem heimisch wurden.
Mein Ziel ist Clearwater,
ein Dorf mit etwa 2'500 Einwohnern.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ein paar Kilometer weiter draussen,
im Wald,
liegt das Haus von Familie Volk.
* Bellen *
- Ja.
Ihr Hund Jackson
begrüsst mich als Erster.
Ja, hier draussen
braucht man einen Wächter. Hallo.
Na? Du bist ein zutraulicher Kerl,
was?
Muss ich hier klingeln?
* Jackson bellt. *
So, nicht wahr?
* Mona lacht. *
Er will auch rein.
* Lachen *
Hallo.- Hallo zusammen.
Hallo, Lisa.
- Hi.
Christian.
- Hallo, Mona.
Simone.
- Hallo.
Gion, freut mich.
Hey, super.
Und ihr habt extra für uns
Winterstimmung gemacht?
Ja, er kam nochmals zurück.
- Leider.
Leider?
Aber ihr seid das ja gewohnt.
- Sechs Monate lang liegt Schnee.
Es ist nicht immer so kalt,
manchmal ist es auch noch kälter.
Was für Temperaturen ...
- Wir hatten mal -38 °C.
Ja, es herrschte
eine Woche lang -38 °C.
Mögt ihr den Winter?
In der Schweiz dachten wir immer:
"Wir wollen Schnee!"
Wir hätten uns
nie vorstellen können,
dass man irgendwann
genug hat von diesem Schnee,
aber man hat definitiv genug davon.
Gehen wir rauf?
- Ja.
Ich habe noch viel mehr Fragen,
aber zuerst blicken wir zurück.
Sommer 2015:
Mit grossen Plänen stürzen sich
Christian und Simone Volk
ins Auswandererabenteuer.
Ihr Startkapital:
zwei tonnenschwere
Holzerntemaschinen.
* Hupen *
So ...
(Gespielt traurig)
Oh, jetzt sind sie weg!
* Hupkonzert *
Im Auftrag eines Sägewerks
wollen sie in Kanada
Waldwirtschaft
in steilem Gelände betreiben.
Ihr Blockhaus in Benken
haben Simone und Christian verkauft
und bereits fast komplett geräumt.
Aber dann wird ihr Antrag für die Ar-
beitsbewilligung in Kanada abgelehnt.
Dass das passiert, hätten wir uns
nie vorstellen können.
Das ist jetzt einfach unmöglich.
Wir haben genau das erfüllt,
was sie wollen:
Wir bringen ihnen Kapital,
haben eine Firma,
schaffen viele Arbeitsplätze,
haben eine innovative Technik,
die sie gar nicht kennen,
aber unbedingt benötigen,
wir haben Verträge ...
Wir wissen einfach nicht,
was daran nicht passt.
Das versteht niemand.
Wir hätten nie damit gerechnet.
Aufgeben ist keine Option.
Das ist jetzt ganz neu.
Du musst hier unterschreiben.
Sie stellen einen neuen Antrag.
Und diesmal klappt's:
Das ersehnte Visum ist da.
Warum der Antrag zuerst abgelehnt
und dann doch bewilligt wurde -
die Familie weiss es bis heute nicht.
In Kanada wartet viel Platz auf sie.
* Simone lacht. *
Oh, wow!
Das neue Zuhause in Clearwater
ist 450 m2 gross
und hat sechs Zimmer.
Hier kommt unser Bett rein.
- Nicht schlecht.
Christian beginnt sofort zu arbeiten.
Die Spezialisierung auf den Steilhang
kommt an:
Es gibt viele Aufträge des Sägewerks
für seine Firma.
Der sechsjährige Gion
geht in Clearwater zur Schule.
Trotz eines langen Wegs
und Sprachschwierigkeiten
lebt er sich rasch ein.
Good morning.
- Good morning.
Simone fällt das Ankommen in Kanada
etwas weniger leicht.
Anfangs
hatte ich ziemliches Heimweh.
Die Männer
hatten überhaupt nie Heimweh,
aber ich anfangs schon.
Damals sagte ich zu Christian:
"Wenn das so bleibt,
bleibe ich nicht in diesem Land."
Mir geht es viel besser,
seit ich den Hund habe.
Ich habe viel weniger Heimweh.
Die Firma boomt.
Familie Volk
kauft zusätzliche Maschinen,
stellt Mitarbeiter ein
und zahlt Steuern.
Die perfekten Einwanderer -
könnte man meinen.
Aber die dauerhafte
Aufenthaltsbewilligung,
die Simone schon lange beantragt hat,
kommt und kommt nicht.
* Seufzen *
Das ist wieder super.
Einer unserer beiden Permanent-
Resident-Anträge wurde abgelehnt.
Ja, hallo.
Welcher denn?
Okay. Jetzt haben wir noch einen,
und dann ist es gelaufen.
Das Problem:
Ohne Aufenthaltsbewilligung
dürfen sie nicht im Land bleiben.
Was ist hier los?
- Du hast es ja gehört, oder?
Oh, Mann.
(Leise)
Was für ein verdammter Scheissdreck.
Es ist echt wie ein schlechter Witz.
Ich weiss auch nicht,
was wir tun sollen.
Familie Volk muss nochmals
ein ganzes Jahr lang kämpfen.
Juhe!
Dann, im Sommer 2018, die Erlösung:
Endlich
ist die Aufenthaltsbewilligung da.
Und mit der Geburt der kleinen Lisa
scheint das Glück perfekt.
Herzliche Gratulation.
- Danke schön.
* Lachen *
Es hat sich einiges verändert
seit dem letzten Mal.
Etwas mehr Spielzeug.
- Ja, ich schaute mich gerade um.
Das letzte Mal, als ich hier war,
war Lisa gerade zur Welt gekommen.
Sie war ein vier Wochen altes Baby.
Wo steht ihr jetzt?
Mit der Aufenthaltsbewilligung
sind wir noch einen Schritt weiter.
Was ist das?
- Wir sind jetzt Kanadier.
Wir haben die kanadische
Staatsbürgerschaft.- Ja.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
Dieses Jahr war es endlich so weit.
- Ihr habt den Pass?- Ja.
Man darf also gratulieren?
- Ja, das war die letzte Stufe.
Wir haben
die Aufnahmeprüfung bestanden.
Dann
kam die Einladung zur Einbürgerung
und wir erledigten das am Computer.
Dann gab es
eine etwa zweistündige Feier
und wir mussten
auf den König schwören.
Auf King Charles.
- Auf King Charles, da er ja ...
Ist es nicht etwas seltsam,
auf einen König zu schwören?- Doch.
Mit Königen haben wir in der Schweiz
ja gar nichts zu tun.
Das störte mich überhaupt nicht.
- Du bist auch Deutsche.
Ich hätte auf alles geschworen,
um endlich diesen Wisch zu kriegen.
Scheissegal,
ich wollte einfach das hier.
Was bedeutet das jetzt für euch?
- Freiheit.
Dass wir hierbleiben dürfen.
Ja, und er kann in die Schweiz und
danach immer wieder zurückkommen.
Sie können uns
nicht mehr rausschmeissen.
Das zeigt,
dass man alles erreichen kann,
wenn man die richtige Frau heiratet.
Das hat er jetzt aber schön gesagt.
Das ist total schön: welcome home -
willkommen zu Hause.
Fühlt es sich auch so an?
- Die Schweiz gab mir extrem viel.
Ich bin immer noch Schweizer.
- Ja.
Und wir denken in Bezug auf viele
Dinge immer noch wie Schweizer.
Ich nicht.
* Alle lachen. *
Kanadisch ist nicht nur der Pass,
sondern auch
die Grösse des Grundstücks:
130 ha,
so gross wie 180 Fussballfelder.
Schafe.
- Was, hier sind Schafe?
Rudy!
Wem gehören diese Schafe?
- Das sind alles meine.
Wer füttert sie? Auch du?
- Ja, ich. Alle Tiere gehören mir.
Du bist eine richtige Bäuerin
geworden.- Ja, ja.
Wir hatten nicht mal einen Hund,
nur Katzen.
Irgendwann
begannen wir mit der Kuhhaltung,
und mittlerweile mussten wir
schon Kälber rausholen,
weil sie falsch lagen.
Hier gibt es ja keinen Tierarzt
bzw. der Tierarzt ist
für einen 80-km-Radius
um Kamloops herum zuständig.
Man muss wirklich Glück haben,
dass er kommen kann.
Bis vor ein paar Jahren
stand rund ums Haus dichter Wald.
Nun gibt es hier Weiden
und Tiergehege.
Die gönnte ich mir kürzlich.
Ich wollte schon immer
eine Highland-Kuh.
Das ist Blondie.
Ist sie nicht schön?
Was war das für ein Moment,
als du dir deine erste Kuh kauftest?
Anfangs
war es total unromantisch.
Wir begannen mit der Kuhhaltung,
weil das Logging nicht mehr klappte.
Die Holzfällerei.- Ja, mit der
Holzfällerei klappte es nicht mehr.
Daher wollten wir
etwas mit Cabins machen.
Tourismus.
Hütten bauen?- Ja, aber wir
befinden uns auf agriculture land.
Landwirtschaftsland.- Genau,
Tourismus ist hier nicht möglich,
ausser man hat eine Landwirtschaft.
Daher entschieden wir uns
irgendwann dafür, Kühe zu halten.
Das war der grosse Einschnitt.
Ihr kamt hierher, weil ihr einen
Vertrag mit der Holzfabrik hattet.
Es hiess: "Wir brauchen euch.
Wir haben viel Arbeit."
Ja, 2018
wurde das Ganze noch gepusht.
Sie wollten mehr Maschinen,
Investitionen
und eine Vergrösserung des Vertrags.
Ja, du stelltest Leute ein.
- Wir investierten richtig viel.
Im Dezember schaute ich mir
eine grosse Arbeit mit dem Chef an.
Mama, come on!
- Ich komme gleich.
Dann sagte er,
der Preis des Holzes würde fallen.
Ich kriegte ein bisschen Panik
und dachte an meine ganzen
Investitionen und Zahlungen.
Diese Kosten hast du ja.
- Genau.
Dann gab ich
dem Maschinenhändler Bescheid.
Um zu verkaufen?
- Ja.
Ja, und dieser ...
* Lautes Muhen *
... fand nach zwei Monaten
einen Käufer,
der eine gebrauchte
und eine neue Maschine übernahm.
Der Verkaufspreis
betrug 1'250'000 ¤.
Am Freitag
schickte er die Anzahlung,
und am Montag
informierte mich der Sägereichef,
dass die Sägerei
permanent geschlossen wird.
Von da an
war das halbe Dorf arbeitslos.
Auch Familie Volk musste
fast alle Mitarbeiter entlassen.
Ihr habt das alles aufgebaut,
dann wird die Fabrik geschlossen
und ihr fangt bei null an.
Dachtet ihr über eine Rückkehr nach?
Ja, wir schauten uns in der Schweiz
Häuser bzw. Bauplätze an.
Wirklich?- Ja, wir waren
noch nie so nah dran wie damals.
Wer war eher dafür?
- Ich.
Immer ich.
- Tatsächlich?- Ja, ja.
Die Holzwirtschaft in der Gegend
kam praktisch zum Stillstand.
Ein Jahr lang gab es
für Christian kaum Aufträge.
Aber dann erholte sich
der Markt langsam.
Heute beschäftigt seine Firma
vier Vollzeit-
und zwei Teilzeitmitarbeitende -
ein Drittel weniger
als vor der Krise.
Ihr habt wirklich
einen richtigen Bauernhof.
Einen kleinen.
- Ja, das kann man schon sagen.
Schau, da kommt George.
* Lachen *
Unser Vogel. Er hätte ihn
lieber auf dem Teller als im Stall.
Er versteht nicht,
dass wir ihn nicht essen wollen.
Wirklich?- Alle Tiere mit Namen
werden nicht gegessen.
Das kann ich nicht.
Er ist total handzahm.
Normalerweise
folgt er uns überallhin.
Wie ein Hund?
- Ja, beim Schlitteln kommt er mit.
Fast 50 Tiere
muss Simone mittlerweile versorgen.
Viel Arbeit, aber auch eine Aufgabe,
die ihr Freude macht.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Der zwölfjährige Gion
interessiert sich eher
für die kleineren Lebewesen:
Echsen, Frösche und Fische.
Aber er träumt v.a. davon,
Pilot zu werden.
Seit einem Dreivierteljahr
geht er regelmässig ins Training
zu den Luftkadetten,
den Royal Canadian Air Cadets.
Soll ich dir ein Tuch geben, Johnny?
Ah, ihr habt eine richtige Uniform.
Gion, kannst du mir erklären,
was du genau machst?
Es geht darum,
wie man Flugzeuge fliegt.
Es geht ums Fliegen. Das Ziel ist,
dass ihr Piloten werdet.- Ja.
Aber es sieht ziemlich
militärisch aus. Ist das so?
Es ist militärisch.
Das ist das Jugendmilitär.- Aha.
Sie werden gedrillt, müssen stramm-
stehen und lernen zu marschieren.
Das macht ihr bestimmt
jedes Mal 1 Std. lang.- Ja.
Sie rufen deinen Namen auf
und dann muss man "Sir" sagen.
Es ist wirklich militärisch.
- "Sir!" und dann strammstehen?
Ja.
- Ich kenne mich damit nicht aus.
Du musst das noch schliessen.
Das klingt nicht wie etwas,
das ich freiwillig machen würde.
Macht das Spass?
- Ja.
Wir können dort viel lernen.
Mich erstaunt es, dass es ihm
so gut gefällt. Es ist knallhart.
Es ist wie im Militär.
Wenn man nicht richtig dasteht,
kriegt man etwas zu hören.
Dort mitzumachen,
bringt ihnen fürs Leben sehr viel.
Du willst nicht Holzfäller werden?
- Nein.
Ich finde es langweilig.
Es ist immer dasselbe.
Man bewegt den Joystick hin und her
und drückt einen Knopf,
um einen Baum zu fällen.
Das kannst du nur sagen,
weil dein Vater nicht da ist.
Der würde dir Saures geben,
wenn er das hören würde.
Immer noch? Ein Flugzeug zu fliegen
ist einfach cooler.
Dann ist man
mit den Vögeln in der Luft.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Gions Traum vom Fliegen
fordert einiges von Simone.
Fürs Training müssen sie 120 km
bis in die nächste Stadt,
nach Kamloops, fahren.
Es geht auch ins Geld.
Das Benzin ist momentan
auch nicht mehr gratis, daher ...
Es ist eigentlich verrückt.
Aber das ist halt so.
Wenn man in Clearwater wohnt
und seinen Kindern
etwas ermöglichen will -
sei es ein spezieller Sport,
die Kadetten usw. -,
muss man einfach nach Kamloops.
Das ist halt der Preis,
den man bezahlen muss.
Es wird ein langer Abend
für die beiden.
Knapp 7 Std.
sind sie zusammen unterwegs.
Wenn Simone weg ist,
kümmert sich Christian um Lisa.
Sie feuern den Ofen des Hauses ein.
Die Temperaturen
liegen immer noch weit unter 0 °C.
* Lisa spricht unverständlich. *
Ja, geh mal rein.
Cold.
Hä? Frierst du?
Du trägst keine Handschuhe, was?
Oh, so gross.
- Jetzt einen grossen darauflegen.
Einen grossen?
- Ja.
Ja, dann ist es gut.
Na? Gut.
Zum Abendessen gibt es
an diesen Abenden immer dasselbe:
Red noodles, wie sie Lisa nennt.
Sie spricht auch zu Hause
fast nur englisch,
ganz anders als ihr Bruder.
Kürzlich kam er nach Hause und
sagte, er sei "befördert" worden.
Nun habe er bereits
einen höheren Rang in der Army,
als ich ihn je gehabt hätte.
Das macht einen schon stolz,
da er sonst ja nicht so ...
... exakt ist.
Aber dort müssen sie halt.
Er zieht es durch und geht gern
und fleissig ins Training.
Wenn er es
als Pilot wirklich schafft,
kann er hier ein gutes Leben führen.
Denn was wir machen,
ist schon ein toughes Business.
Lisa, Abendessen!
Stell ihn hin.
Lisa, leg den Computer weg.
* Lisa lacht. *
(Amüsiert) Doch, ganz bestimmt.
Nicht wahr?
* Geräusch aus dem Computer *
Schalt ihn jetzt aus.
Komm, Schluss jetzt.
* Lisa kichert. *
Herrgott.
Ausschalten, Schluss jetzt.
(Undeutlich) Which one is smaller?
Nimm mal den Schnuller raus.
Just a little bit.
Danach noch ein bisschen spielen,
und dann ist schon bald
Lichterlöschen für beide.
Die Nacht ist kurz. Um 5 Uhr ist bei
Familie Volk schon wieder Tagwache.
Simone ist immer die Erste.
Sie macht Kaffee und Frühstück.
Christian, schneid
etwas Brot zum Mitnehmen ab.
Ich darf ihr nie helfen,
mein Mittagessen zu machen.
Er darf auch nicht hinschauen.
Ja, sonst ist es
keine Überraschung mehr.- Wirklich?
Dass er mir eine Scheibe Brot gibt,
ist schon grenzwertig.
Jetzt weiss er, dass es Brot gibt.
Um 6 Uhr geht's los -
spät für kanadische Verhältnisse.
Andere Holzfäller
beginnen schon um 2 Uhr nachts.
Wohin gehen wir?
In eines der drei Einschlaggebiete
der Sägerei, für die wir arbeiten.
Das Einschlaggebiet selbst
ist so gross wie der Kanton Thurgau.
So riesig ist euer Einzugsgebiet?
- Ja, genau, eines dieser drei.
Heute fahren wir die Route 2 hoch,
dann über die 7A und hier ist
der Ort, wo wir zurzeit arbeiten.
Momentan arbeiten dort oben
fünf Holzfällerunternehmen.
Pro Tag gelangen etwa 100 Schweizer
Lastwagenladungen auf diese Strasse.
Oh! So viel? Von welchen
Temperaturen sprechen wir heute?
Dort oben wir es 5-7 °C kälter sein,
wahrscheinlich etwa -25 °C.
Okay.- Also
perfekte Einschlagbedingungen.
Ja, ja.
Und mit dem Wind sind es gefühlt
etwa -30 °C?- Wahrscheinlich.
-30 °C: Dann zieht sich
sogar Christian einen Pullover über.
So.
Ich montierte alles,
was mein Koffer hergab,
und darüber
noch Gions Schneemobilanzug.
Mehr Schichten sind nicht möglich.
* Sie lacht. *
Wenn das nicht reicht, reicht nichts.
Handschuhe hast du?
- Ja.
* Nachdenkliche E-Gitarrenklänge *
In Clearwater
macht Christian einen Zwischenstopp.
Hello.
* Er lacht. *
How's it going? Pretty good?
* Christian lacht. *
Im Werkzeuggeschäft
ist er Stammkunde.
Hier erhält er wichtige Ersatzteile
und was er sonst noch benötigt.
Als ich hier anfing, wollte mir
niemand wirklich etwas verkaufen.
Dann kam ich hier rein und sagte:
"Hier ist ein Scheck über 10'000 ¤.
Von nun an kaufe ich hier ein."
"Wenn er aufgebraucht ist,
geht es auf Rechnung."
Sie sagten: "Okay."
Seit ich den Scheck hinlegte,
läuft das Geschäft.
So sprach sich im Dorf rasch herum,
dass wir bezahlen.
Wir haben uns auch angewöhnt,
die Rechnung nicht
nach 30 oder nach 10 Tagen,
sondern noch
am selben Tag zu bezahlen.
Das ist immer noch so.
Wenn ich etwas brauche,
kriege ich es.
You are heading up the mountain?
- Yeah, we're heading up now.
Perfect. Nice cold day out there.
Auch Simone ist schon unterwegs.
Es ist kalt, was?
- Ja.
Sie ist mit Anja verabredet, der
Ehefrau eines Schweizer Mitarbeiters.
Die beiden bereiten zusammen
das Schulfrühstück vor.
Super, danke.
Knapp 100 Kinder kriegen
dreimal pro Woche gratis Frühstück.
Das ist ein bisschen mein Baby,
nicht wahr?- Ja.
Die meisten Kinder
haben schon etwas zu essen dabei,
aber oft nur
eine Tüte Chips oder ...
... irgendwelche Snacks.
Viele dieser Dinge kennen sie
gar nicht.- Nichts Gesundes.
Es begann,
als die Sägerei geschlossen wurde.
Das war der erste grosse
Schicksalsschlag fürs Dorf.
Als sich die Holzwirtschaft
wieder etwas erholt hatte,
kam Covid.
Man merkte, dass viele Leute
kein Geld mehr hatten.
Finanziert wird das Schulfrühstück
ausschliesslich durch Spenden.
Acht ehrenamtliche Helfer
unterstützen Simone.
Wenn es nach ihr ginge, würde sie
das Frühstück täglich anbieten.
Es ist wirklich befriedigend,
wenn man sieht,
wie sich die Kinder darüber freuen
und dankbar sind.
Auch die Lehrer sagen, dass sie bei
den Kindern einen Unterschied sehen,
seit es das Frühstück gibt.
Sie haben etwas im Bauch
und einen guten Start in den Tag.
(Gion) Und sie können sich
konzentrieren.- Ja.
So. Jetzt kannst du es
darüberstreuen.
Filmen konnten wir
das Frühstück nicht.
Sobald der erste Schulbus
mit Kindern ankam,
mussten wir die Kamera ausschalten.
Bis zum Holzschlag sind wir
eine Dreiviertelstunde unterwegs.
(Mann über Funk) Get out of the way.
* Mona lacht. *
No panic, have a safe trip.
(Mann über Funk) Hello, guys.
- Going down once.
Diesen Kanal hören wir,
wenn geladene Trucks runterkommen.
Die Holz-Lkw haben immer Vorfahrt.
- Ah, okay.
Damit man nicht überrollt wird.
- Ja.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Auch wenn Christians Geschäft
wieder läuft,
hat sich die Holzwirtschaft
in Clearwater
nicht mehr ganz von der Krise erholt.
Heute gibt es nur noch halb so viel
Holzereiunternehmen wie zuvor.
Denen will man nicht im Weg stehen.
Nein, da geht man besser zur Seite.
Das ist eine aufgeforstete Fläche,
die wohl etwa 30 Jahre alt ist.
Und das da oben?
Das wurde wohl
vor fünf Jahren abgeholzt.
In Kanada gehört der Wald
zu 90 % dem Staat.
Heading in the block here.
(Mann über Funk)
Kind of in the middle there,
where Andy was yesterday.
Christians aktueller Schlag:
4'000 m3 Holz -
fast zehnmal mehr, als er früher
bei Aufträgen in der Schweiz hatte.
Wenn man diese Faszination
für die Holzfällerei hat,
ist das schon the place to be.
Verdienst du mehr als in der Schweiz?
- Nein.
Gleich viel?
- Nein.- Weniger?
Ja.
- Echt? Wieso denn?
Die Margen sind knapper.
- Ja.
Wegen des Geldes
muss man es nicht machen.
Weshalb tust du es dann?
- Ich weiss auch nicht.
Weil ich hier leben will,
und es die grosse Freiheit ist.
Die Maschine ist warm genug, und
Christian macht sich an die Arbeit.
41 t schwer ist Sweety,
seine riesige Holzerntemaschine.
* Krachen *
Meine Güte,
das hat eine extreme Gewalt.
Für mich sieht das brutal aus.
Tut es dir nicht auch fast weh,
das zu sehen?
So funktioniert die Holzwirtschaft.
Aber manchmal nervt es mich,
weil man mit wenig Aufwand
etwas viel Besseres machen könnte.
In der Schweiz sind solche
Kahlschläge ja schon lange verboten -
aus guten Gründen, weil sie
ökologisch eine Katastrophe sind.
Mindestens drei Viertel
der Holzwirtschaft auf der Welt
besteht aus Kahlschlägen.
Das ist die Normalität.
Was wir in Europa tun,
ist die Ausnahme.
Aber es wäre besser.
- Ja, es wäre besser.
Die Tatsache, dass die meisten
mit Kahlschlägen arbeiten,
rechtfertigt das Ganze nicht.
Nein, aber in diesen Beständen ...
Ich hatte schon viele Diskussionen
bezüglich Durchforstung.
Das Problem ist, dass man sie
nicht durchforsten kann.
Dann fallen sie in sich zusammen.
Wenn man nur den Müll entfernen
und die gesunden Bäume stehen
lassen will, hat niemand Lust dazu.
Dann gibt es keinen Anreiz.
Wenn dem Staat, dem das Land gehört,
ein finanzieller Vorteil entsteht,
tut man es, und wenn nicht,
lässt man es so, wie es ist.
Eine einfache Lösung für
dieses Dilemma ist nicht in Sicht.
Aber die Holzwirtschaft
sei auch in Kanada im Wandel -
in Richtung Nachhaltigkeit.
Für Christian und seine Mitarbeiter
ein Vorteil.
Dank ihres Know-hows
aus der Schweizer Waldwirtschaft
erhalten sie neue Aufträge.
Ich kann mir schon vorstellen,
weshalb man gern im Wald arbeitet.
Es hat auch nicht immer -20 °C.
Okay, also ...
- Ich meine ...
Das brauchst du auch nicht täglich.
- Nein, das braucht keiner.
Aber ansonsten stimmt es für dich.
Dich macht es zufrieden, einen
Baum nach dem anderen zu fällen, was?
Ja.
Man kann darüber diskutieren,
ob das, was wir tun,
die beste Vorgehensweise ist.
Aber wenn ich es tue und etwas ver-
bessern kann, verändere ich etwas.
Wenn ich es nicht mehr mache,
machen sie es immer noch
und bestimmt nicht besser.
Vielleicht
liegen wir etwas über dem Minimum,
und die anderen
liegen eher darunter.
Das ist mein erstes Picknick
bei -20 C.- Tatsächlich?- Mhm.
Mein Ei ist wirklich gefroren.
Der Käse wird nicht warm.
Zurück auf dem Hof von Familie Volk.
Simone holt Siloballen
für ihre Tiere.
Diese Ballen hat Christian
im Sommer selbst gepresst.
Ah, dieser Scheissschnee überall!
* Verärgertes Stöhnen *
Dadurch ist alles
immer 500-mal anstrengender.
Einen Stall
hat Familie Volk noch nicht.
Für die Tiere
sei das aber kein Problem.
Die haben Hunger, was?
- Ja, die haben Hunger.
Sie brauchen einfach mehr Futter.
Es öffnet sich fast nicht.
Geh weg, Belina.
So, jetzt.
- Wie viele hast du hier?
13.
(Beruhigend) Ja, ja, ist ja gut.
Schau mal.
Wenn mein Mann
das täglich machen müsste,
hätten wir
schon lange eine Maschine dafür.
Er würde das
nicht zweimal täglich machen.
Christian kam hierher
und wusste von Anfang an,
dass er mit grossen Maschinen
im Wald Bäume fällen will.
Bei dir war das weniger klar.
- Ja.
Das ist bei Frauen oft so.
Die Männer kommen hierher
und haben ihren Beruf.
Sie haben es oft leichter. Sie tun
das, was sie zuvor schon taten.
Wir Frauen kommen hierher
und dann ...
Was half dir,
um letztlich deine Rolle zu finden?
In der Schweiz verdiente ich
immer mein eigenes Geld.
Dann kam ich hierher und ...
Das mochte ich noch nie.
Ich will auch gerne ...
Natürlich erledigte ich die
Büroarbeit für die Firma, aber ...
Du willst nicht von Christians Arbeit
abhängig sein?- Genau.
Er ist so erfolgreich
mit seiner Firma und ich habe ...
Das mit den Tieren ist schon schön.
Man lernt sehr viel.
Ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich mal
so bei einer Kuh hinten reinfasse.
Um das Kalb zu drehen?
- Ja.
Hätte man mir das früher gesagt,
hätte ich geantwortet: "Spinnst du?"
Simone -
über Learning by Doing zur Bäuerin.
Wie machst du das jeweils allein?
* Simone lacht. *
Wie gesagt: Mein Mann hätte
schon lange eine Maschine dafür.
Ja.
Die neue Rolle half Simone,
ihren Platz in Kanada zu finden.
* Ächzen *
In Christians Werkstatt
ist jeden Freitagabend Betrieb.
Deine Medizin.
Mmh.
Familie Volks Feierabendbier hatte
schon in der Schweiz Tradition,
und die Kanadier übernehmen
diesen Brauch begeistert.
Hallo.
You're looking good.
Zuerst
waren nur die Mitarbeiter dabei,
nun kommen auch Nachbarn und Freunde.
Für die harten Arbeiter.
Ein geselliger Ausklang
der Arbeitswoche.
* Entspannte Musik *
Mein letzter Tag
bringt eine Überraschung.
Ein Blizzard brachte über Nacht
fast 50 cm Schnee.
Am einzigen Kreisel von Clearwater
geht nichts mehr.
Und auch die Fahrt vom Hotel zu
Familie Volk wird zu einem Abenteuer.
Jetzt habe ich wirklich Schiss.
Hier hat noch niemand
die Strassen freigeräumt.
Hier ist ihre Einfahrt,
aber da komme ich nicht rein.
* Abwartende Gitarrenklänge *
Okay.
Ohne Schneemobil ist man hier
in den nächsten Tagen verloren.
Und ohne Traktor sowieso,
wenn man wie Familie Volk
draussen im Wald wohnt.
4 Std. benötigen sie,
um alle Wege zu pflügen,
so gross ist ihr Grundstück.
In diesem Schnee
ersäuft man schlichtweg.
Es ist Wochenende, aber bei Familie
Volk gibt es immer etwas zu tun.
Christian und Gion
holen einen Tisch ab,
den sie bei einem befreundeten
Schreiner bestellten.
Das ist er schon.
- Auch er spricht deutsch.
Hallo.
Schreiner Lorenz kommt aus Südtirol.
Haben sie bei dir Junge gekriegt?
- Ja, deshalb sind sie im Anhänger.
Aha, damit ihnen warm ist?
- An Weihnachten, bei -35 °C.
Hast du gefrühstückt? Bist du fit?
- (Lachend) Ja, ja.
Ich habe Gion dabei,
er hilft auch beim Tragen.
Der Tisch ist für ein Ferienhaus,
das Familie Volk renovierte
und vermieten will.
* Ächzen *
Vielen Dank, mach's gut.
Mach ihn nicht kaputt,
bevor er zu Hause ist.
Die Garantie ist schon abgelaufen.
* Piff *
Hey!
Christian muss nicht weit fahren.
Das Ferienhaus
steht auf dem Nachbargrundstück,
das sie vor zwei Jahren
dazukaufen konnten -
zusammen mit zwei anderen Häusern.
So, hast du den Tisch?
- Jawohl.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das Blockhaus wurde von Siedlern
gebaut und ist knapp 100 Jahre alt.
Das ist ja alles original.
Originales Holz.
- Originales Holz wie früher.
Es war einfach eine Hütte.
- Ja, eine Hütte.
Es gab keinen Strom und kein Wasser.
Das andere Homestead
haben wir schon renoviert
und es war
den ganzen Sommer lang voll.
Eigentlich
hätte es ein ganz rustikales,
minimalistisches Häuschen
sein sollen,
aber nun haben wir
Solarpanels auf dem Dach,
eine Dusche, eine Toilette etc.
Könntest du dir vorstellen,
so zu leben?
Irgendwann.
Wenn die Kinder gross sind,
sollen sie das Haus übernehmen ...
... und wir bauen uns oben ...
... ein kleines Blockhaus
und leben dort.
Das Häuschen
will Simone an Feriengäste vermieten.
Ein zusätzliches finanzielles
Standbein für die Familie.
Mit den passenden Stühlen
ist das ...
Die fertigt er noch an.
- ... tipptopp.
Superschön.
Der Start in Kanada
war für Familie Volk harzig,
und auch später
lief der Motor nicht immer rund.
Aber Simone und Christian
haben ihre Lektion gelernt,
und wenn sich neue Probleme
auftürmen, wissen sie nun,
wie sie damit umgehen müssen.
* Lachen *
Hey, das ist ja total cool.
* Muntere glockige Klänge *
* Lachen *
Wenn ihr vorher gewusst hättet,
welche Hindernisse
ihr hier überwinden müsst -
wärt ihr trotzdem ausgewandert?
Hättest du mich vor zwei Jahren
gefragt: ganz klar nein.
Dieser Meinung wären wir
wohl beide gewesen.- Ja.
Aber jetzt steht ihr trotzdem hier
und ich habe den Eindruck,
dass es für euch so stimmt.
Ja, zurzeit ist es perfekt.
- Ja, es ist herrlich.
Der Laden läuft.
- Und wir sind keine Fremden mehr.
Wir sind dabei, wir gehören dazu.
Man hat extrem viele Möglichkeiten
und in seiner Freizeit
kann man fast alles tun,
was man will.
Z.B. selbst eine Ski-
oder Schlittelpiste bauen.
Der Druck und der Stress
sind nicht kleiner,
aber für die Familie ...
Du siehst Lisa eher aufwachsen
als Gion, als er in ihrem Alter war,
weil du öfter da bist.
Auch den Tiere gibt man etwas,
das sie in der Schweiz nicht hätten.
Hier
hat man viel mehr Möglichkeiten.
Wenn man ein Geschäft aufbaut
und seine Sache gut macht,
wird man erfolgreich sein.
Ein Faktor, der dazu führte,
dass es bei euch klappte,
seid meiner Meinung nach ihr beide.
Ihr seid sehr unterschiedlich und
ergänzt euch sehr gut. Stimmt das?
Ja, ich denke schon.
- Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Man muss am selben Strang ziehen.
- Was hast du an ihm?
Na, schau ihn dir an.
Was habe ich nicht?
Er ist einfach
der Fels in der Brandung.
Ich mache mir Sorgen, bin ängstlich
und er sagt: "Alles wird gut."
Nicht wahr?
* Ausgelassene Schreie *
Wow!
Jemand, der Gas gibt, und jemand,
der weiss, wie man bremst.
Für Familie Volk wendete sich
in Kanada alles zum Besten.
# Sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023